devil fruits are one of the wildest and
most mysterious power systems in all of
manga eating one of these fruits gives
the user a unique special ability but
with a major trade-off anyone who's
eaten a devil fruit loses the ability to
swim which isn't too convenient in a
world that's mostly ocean there are
three main types of devil fruits zones
which turn the user into an animal or
mythical creature logias which give the
user the ability to turn into and
produce unlimited quantities of an
element and paramecius which do
everything else really if a devil fruit
user attempts to eat a second devil
fruit the legend has it that they'll die
unless of course they're blackbeard who
has somehow managed to eat two devil
fruits and wield two powers at once and
speaking of devil fruit users dying when
one does the fruit is reincarnated into
the nearest normal piece of fruit ready
to be eaten by its next user how are
these fruits created and what secrets do
they still hold we won't know for sure
until we learn the lost history of the
ancient kingdom and that's because